Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能通过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic, award-winning vehicle has been redefined with a distinctive, modern design. A reimagined exterior features compelling proportions and precise detailing. Built with integrity and purpose, the interior boasts robust, durable materials. Whether it's the all-terrain capability, ample cargo capacity, or innovative camera technology, the Defender 110 lets you go further and do more. And with seating for up to seven, everyone can enjoy the journey.
保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。对于那些拥抱不可能的人来说，卫士 110（Defender 110）已准备好迎接冒险。这款标志性的获奖车型以独特、现代的设计进行了重新定义。重新构想的外观具有引人注目的比例和精确的细节。内饰秉承诚信与宗旨，采用了坚固耐用的材料。无论是全地形能力、充足的载货空间，还是创新的摄像头技术，卫士 110 都能让您走得更远，做得更多。而且最多可容纳七人，让每个人都能享受旅程。
Learn more at LandRover.ca. Adelweiss, Adelweiss Every morning you greet me Small and white, clean and bright You look happy to meet me Blossom of snow snow may you bloom and grow bloom and grow forever edelweiss edelweiss bless my homeland forever. Edelweiss. Edel... That, Dominic, was Christopher Plummer as Captain Von Trapp.
了解更多信息请访问 LandRover.ca。雪绒花，雪绒花，每天清晨你向我问候，洁白小巧，纯净明亮，你看起来很高兴见到我。雪之花，愿你绽放生长，永远绽放生长。雪绒花，雪绒花，永远祝福我的家园。雪绒花。雪绒……多米尼克，刚才那是克里斯托弗·普卢默饰演的冯·特拉普上校。
And he is standing on the stage of the Salzburg Festival. He has his children and his new wife, Julie Andrews. Waiting in the wings, Maria, and they are engaged in a complicated plot to escape Nazi-dominated Austria because Captain von Tra Music, the famous Rodgers and Hammerstein musical, which was turned into a film in 1965, the von Trapp family will be escaping because von Trapp has been summoned to serve in the new German Navy. And he doesn't want to do it because he's a principled anti-Nazi. And so the von Trapps go heading off into the mountains and they cross into Switzerland. And as you have often pointed out yourself, Dominic, more people listened to The Sound of Music in the 60s than they did to Sgt.
他正站在萨尔茨堡音乐节的舞台上。他身边有他的孩子们和他的新婚妻子朱莉·安德鲁斯。玛丽亚在侧幕等待，他们正陷入一个复杂的阴谋，试图逃离纳粹统治下的奥地利，因为冯·特拉普上校……音乐，这部著名的罗杰斯与汉默斯坦音乐剧在 1965 年被改编成电影，冯·特拉普一家将要逃离，因为冯·特拉普被征召去德国新海军服役。他不想去，因为他是一位有原则的反纳粹人士。于是冯·特拉普一家向山里进发，越过边境进入瑞士。正如你经常指出的那样，多米尼克，在 60 年代听《音乐之声》的人比听《佩珀中士》的人还要多。
Pepper. So I guess that as a result of that, The Sound of Music is probably the most celebrated portrayal of the Anschluss, certainly in the anglophone world. And when Christopher Plummer is singing that, he's doing it before an audience that joins in in patriotic unison. And it's kind of framed as being a reaction to the recent German annexation of Austria. And the idea that the Austrians are the first victims of the Nazi expansion has been a very important part of post-war Austrian historiography, hasn't it? Yes, it has.
佩珀。所以我猜，正因如此，《音乐之声》可能是对“德奥合并”（Anschluss）最著名的描绘，至少在英语世界是这样。当克里斯托弗·普卢默演唱那首歌时，他是在一群齐声爱国合唱的观众面前表演的。这在某种程度上被塑造成对近期德国吞并奥地利的一种反应。而“奥地利人是纳粹扩张的首批受害者”这一观点，一直是战后奥地利史学中非常重要的一部分，不是吗？是的，确实如此。
And I guess that today we're looking at the Anschluss, the German takeover of Austria in 1938, and perhaps we could explore the degree to which The Sound of Music is mythologising that Austrian sense of themselves as victims, or whether it's true to history. Yes, absolutely. You're dead right, Tom. The idea that Austria is the first victim of Hitler is a sort of foundational myth of post-war, you know, the Austrian Republic.
我想今天我们要探讨的是“德奥合并”，即 1938 年德国对奥地利的接管，也许我们可以探讨一下《音乐之声》在多大程度上神话了奥地利人作为受害者的自我认知，或者它是否符合历史。是的，绝对是。你说得太对了，汤姆。奥地利是希特勒的首批受害者这一观点，是战后奥地利共和国的一种基础神话。
And it's true that some Austrians are Hitler's victims, no doubt about that. Actually, in the second half, we will be telling some terrible stories about what happened to particularly Jewish Austrians after the Nazi takeover. But there were, of course, Austrian Nazis. And there were many people in Austria who turned out to greet Hitler and were delighted to see him. So it's a very complicated story. Do you know what? Having spent the last 20 years basically trading on the sound of music's popularity in the 1960s it's my fact that i kind of bring out to annoy people it's the ultimate sandbrook fact that i bring out to annoy people it hadn't occurred to me to weave the sound of music into this episode
诚然，有些奥地利人确实是希特勒的受害者，这一点毫无疑问。实际上，在下半部分，我们将讲述一些关于纳粹接管后犹太裔奥地利人所遭遇的可怕故事。但当然，奥地利也有纳粹分子。奥地利有许多人出来迎接希特勒，并为见到他而感到高兴。所以这是一个非常复杂的故事。你知道吗？在过去 20 年里，我基本上靠《音乐之声》在 60 年代的流行来混日子，这是我拿出来烦人的事实，这是我拿出来烦人的终极桑德布鲁克事实，我竟然没想过把《音乐之声》编进这一集里。
well that's that's what teamwork is all about dominic stroke of genius well you know i love teamwork on the rest is history tom i know you do so so that's what the rest of history is all about. Okay. We ended the last episode, which was about Hitler's kind of road to war. The fashioning of the Nazi war machine. Might be another way of putting it. Very good. Mr. Churchill, very good. Yes.
嗯，这就是团队合作的意义所在，多米尼克，天才之举。嗯，你知道我喜欢《历史的余味》里的团队合作，汤姆，我知道你喜欢。所以这就是《历史的余味》的全部意义所在。好的。我们结束了上一集，那一集是关于希特勒的战争之路。打造纳粹战争机器，这可能是另一种说法。非常好。丘吉尔先生，非常好。是的。
We ended with a sort of semi-cliffhanger. He summoned his generals in November 1937. He's going to tell them what his next plan is. But just before we get into telling you what happened at the meeting, we should remind listeners that Hitler is animated throughout by this extraordinary sense of mission, this belief that either Germany becomes the world's preeminent power, conquers the world, or it will be annihilated. There is no middle ground. So with almost any other dictator in history, actually, Mussolini, Franco, even Stalin, there is a kind of halfway house where they will just happily accept stability. Hitler will not. Hitler is restless and he must
我们以一种半悬念的方式结束了那一集。他在 1937 年 11 月召集了他的将军们。他要告诉他们他的下一个计划是什么。但在我们开始讲述会议上发生了什么之前，我们应该提醒听众，希特勒始终被一种非凡的使命感所驱动，他相信德国要么成为世界卓越的强国，征服世界，要么就会被消灭。没有中间地带。所以，实际上，对于历史上几乎任何其他独裁者，墨索里尼、佛朗哥，甚至斯大林，都有某种中间地带，他们会很乐意接受稳定。希特勒不会。希特勒是躁动不安的，他必须
keep moving. He cannot stand still. So he summons his generals to the Reich Chancellery. And as this is want, he talks for two hours. And he says to them, OK, here is the plan. We need living space. We're going to suffer from national sterility if we don't expand. We're actually running out of food, which is true because his economic model is so terrible. We must act, he says, between 1943 and 1945. That is the window. Because after that point, we'll be too old, the birth rate will be in decline, the wheels will have fallen off the economy, and our neighbors will have caught up and rearmed. So that is the moment, 1943 or so. And he says the priority will be to take two
不断前进。他不能停滞不前。于是他召集将军们到帝国总理府。按照他的习惯，他讲了两个小时。他对他们说，好吧，计划是这样的。我们需要生存空间。如果我们不扩张，我们就会遭受民族不育。我们实际上快没食物了，这是真的，因为他的经济模式太糟糕了。他说，我们必须在 1943 年到 1945 年之间采取行动。这就是窗口期。因为在那之后，我们就太老了，出生率会下降，经济的轮子会脱落，我们的邻国也会赶上来并重新武装。所以这就是那个时刻，1943 年左右。他说，首要任务是先拿下两个
countries first, which are Austria and Czechoslovakia. That will secure our eastern borders. Because we've secured our eastern borders, we'll be able to see off the French on the west. And that will be the point from which we can strike further east, Poland, and then the Soviet Union to get the colossal territorial empire that we need. And he says, once we've taken Czechoslovakia and Austria, so 1943 or so, we'll kick out a few million of their people. That will give us a huge food surplus. That means we can feed our population. And who are they proposing to kick out and where? Probably kick them out to the east, force them out. I mean, we will come to this idea about removal and expulsion. Yeah. And how do the generals feel about this? Do they blanch at all at this idea or not? They do. They do blanch at it, Tom. Previously, everything that Hitler
国家，即奥地利和捷克斯洛伐克。这将确保我们的东部边界。因为我们确保了东部边界，我们就能在西部击退法国人。那将是我们进一步向东打击波兰，然后是苏联，以获得我们所需的庞大领土帝国的起点。他说，一旦我们拿下了捷克斯洛伐克和奥地利，也就是 1943 年左右，我们将驱逐他们几百万人。这将给我们带来巨大的粮食盈余。这意味着我们可以养活我们的人口。他们打算把谁赶走，赶到哪里去？大概是把他们赶到东方，强行驱逐。我的意思是，我们将谈到这个关于清除和驱逐的想法。是的。将军们对此感觉如何？他们对这个想法感到畏缩吗？他们确实畏缩了，汤姆。以前，希特勒
had said to his generals whenever he was giving them these rants, they kind of said, yeah, sounds reasonable. He's going a bit faster and more recklessly than we envisaged. But this kind of accords with our aims. Now, this is the first time that they are really alarmed. They are not alarmed at the idea of fighting the Austrians or the Czechs. But are they alarmed at the idea of expelling millions of people? Morally, is there an expression of concern about that? I mean, that's forcing you to face up to what Lebensraum means, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely it is. I just wondered whether there are any moral scruples at all.
每次发表这些长篇大论时，对他的将军们说的话，他们都会说，是的，听起来很合理。他比我们预想的走得更快、更鲁莽。但这符合我们的目标。现在，这是他们第一次真正感到惊慌。他们并不担心与奥地利人或捷克人作战的想法。但他们是否对驱逐数百万人的想法感到惊慌？在道德上，是否有人表达了担忧？我的意思是，这迫使你面对“生存空间”（Lebensraum）意味着什么，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我只是想知道是否还有任何道德顾虑。
I don't think there are. There's no sense for them that there's moral scruples at this stage. That's not their reservation? No, it's not their reservation. Their reservation is, reservation Their reservation is This is going to be Very very Reckless Okay This sounds Like it will mean war With Britain and France
我不认为有。对他们来说，在这个阶段没有道德顾虑。那不是他们的保留意见？不，那不是他们的保留意见。他们的保留意见是……他们的保留意见是……这将会非常、非常鲁莽。好吧，这听起来意味着与英国和法国开战。
With Britain and France And we don't think We're ready You know We might have Sometimes chatted Late at night Over our schnapps
与英国和法国。我们认为我们还没准备好。你知道，我们可能有时在深夜喝着杜松子酒聊天时，
About fighting the French In a spa town Yeah We don't really Fancy doing it And He looks around the room And people like the
谈论在温泉小镇与法国人作战。是的，我们真的不想那样做。他环顾四周，像
defense minister, Wernher von Blomberg, his number two, who's the kind of general in charge of the army, who is Wernher von Fritsch. They are nationalistic, conservative, but they are kind of white with horror at the thought of all this fighting so soon. We're not ready. It's so reckless. And they say, we can't get into a situation where we're fighting Britain and France. We will lose. Now, there is a really interesting argument to be had about whether they could have blocked his ambitions, about whether actually he had gone too far. I mean, maybe he hadn't, but we will never know because extraordinarily at about this point, so just a few weeks later both those two
国防部长维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡，他的二把手，负责军队的将军维尔纳·冯·弗里奇。他们是民族主义者、保守派，但一想到这么快就要进行所有这些战斗，他们就吓得脸色苍白。我们还没准备好。这太鲁莽了。他们说，我们不能陷入与英国和法国作战的境地。我们会输的。现在，关于他们是否能阻止他的野心，关于他是否真的走得太远了，有一个非常有趣的争论。我的意思是，也许他没有，但我们永远不会知道，因为非同寻常的是，就在这个时候，也就是几周后，那两个
men that i mentioned field marshal von blomberg and colonel general fritsch they are forced out in these bizarre scandals that rip out the top echelon of the army leadership and it's very convenient timing for hitler isn't it it's incredibly convenient but the weird thing is he doesn't orchestrate it. Let's say what they are, because they are excellent sex scandals. They're so weird. So first of all, Field Marshal von Bromberg, he's widowed and he has five adult children. One day he's walking in the park in Berlin and he meets this young woman.
我提到的那两个人，陆军元帅冯·勃洛姆堡和大将弗里奇，在这些离奇的丑闻中被迫下台，这摧毁了军队领导层的最高层，这对希特勒来说时间点非常巧合，不是吗？这非常巧合，但奇怪的是，他并没有策划这一切。让我们说说它们是什么，因为它们是极好的性丑闻。它们太奇怪了。首先，陆军元帅冯·勃洛姆堡，他丧偶了，有五个成年子女。有一天他在柏林的公园里散步，遇到了这个年轻女子。
She's 35 years younger than him and he falls passionately in love with her. She's from a much sort of lower social echelon. And he goes to Hitler because Hitler's the supreme commander of the Wehrmacht. So Field Marshal goes to him and he says, I want to marry this girl. She's much younger than me. The girl of the people.
她比他小 35 岁，他疯狂地爱上了她。她来自社会阶层低得多的人群。他去找希特勒，因为希特勒是国防军的最高统帅。所以陆军元帅去找他，说，我想娶这个女孩。她比我年轻得多。平民女孩。
And people will sneer at us and be snobbish. She's a typist, he says, doesn't he? And Hitler says, this is brilliant. Yeah. You know, a girl of the people. Yeah. This is exactly what a man like you should be doing. Absolutely splendid. Dominic, that speech he gave to the Hitler youth at Nuremberg in 1934,
人们会嘲笑我们，会势利眼。她说她是个打字员，不是吗？希特勒说，这太棒了。是的。你知道，平民女孩。是的。这正是像你这样的人应该做的。绝对精彩。多米尼克，他在 1934 年纽伦堡对希特勒青年团发表的那次演讲，
dissolve all social divisions. So this is Nazism in practice. Exactly. And Hitler says, I'll be the witness. I'll be the witness at the wedding. Do you know what? Bring along Goering. I'll bring Goering as my plus one and he'll be the second witness. So they have the wedding. The bride's mother is there. Blomberg's children, Hitler and Goering. What a terrible wedding that is. They get married at the war ministry.
消除所有社会阶级分化。所以这就是实践中的纳粹主义。完全正确。希特勒说，我来做证婚人。我来做婚礼的证婚人。你知道吗？带上戈林。我会带戈林作为我的随从，他将是第二个证婚人。于是他们举行了婚礼。新娘的母亲在场。勃洛姆堡的孩子们，希特勒和戈林。那是一场多么糟糕的婚礼啊。他们在战争部结婚。
Unfortunately, within days of the marriage, it comes to the attention of the police that this woman, A, had once posed for pornographic pictures taken by a Jewish photographer and B, had by a Jewish photographer. And B had been a prostitute. A licensed prostitute, right?
不幸的是，在结婚几天后，警方注意到这个女人，A，曾经为一位犹太摄影师拍摄过色情照片，B，曾经……由一位犹太摄影师拍摄。而且 B 曾经是一名妓女。持证妓女，对吧？
So there's kind of legal trace elements of it. An officially registered prostitute. Yeah. And Goering has to go and see Hitler and say, we've made a terrible mistake. This is very embarrassing. And Hitler is absolutely horrified. Ashen faced. It's typical of Hitler. What Hitler objects to is that he will be embarrassed and everybody will laugh at him.
所以这在法律上有某种痕迹。一名正式注册的妓女。是的。戈林不得不去见希特勒说，我们犯了一个严重的错误。这非常尴尬。希特勒感到非常震惊。脸色苍白。这是希特勒的典型表现。希特勒反对的是他会感到尴尬，每个人都会嘲笑他。
Say he went to a prostitute's wedding and was the chief witness. He's kind of weirdly prissy, isn't he, about things like that? He's very prissy and puritanical. So he basically says, Blomberg has to go. And indeed Blomberg does go. He resigns. They have a sort of big row, but then they end actually in quite sort of amicable terms. They shake hands and he's given a big payoff and off he goes to Italy.
说他去参加了一个妓女的婚礼，还是首席证婚人。他在这些事情上表现得非常古怪、拘谨，不是吗？他非常拘谨和清教徒。所以他基本上说，勃洛姆堡必须走。勃洛姆堡确实走了。他们吵了一架，但最后实际上以相当友好的方式结束了。他们握手，他得到了一大笔遣散费，然后去了意大利。
On a kind of extended honeymoon to Capri. Yes. But this weird thing that Admiral Radar. Yeah. He sends an aide to follow them round and suggests that he commits suicide. And he doesn't, does he? He keeps leaving guns on the marital pillow. That's not very romantic. Yeah. And do you know where he ends up in the war?
在卡普里岛度过了一个延长的蜜月。是的。但雷德尔海军上将那件奇怪的事情。是的。他派了一名助手跟着他们，建议他自杀。他没自杀，对吧？他一直把枪放在婚床上。那不太浪漫。是的。你知道他在战争中最后去了哪里吗？
He dies after the war, doesn't he? He dies after the war, but during the war, he ends up in Bad Vesey, which is where all the action happened in The Night of the Long Knives. What is it with Nazis and spa towns? Spa town hotels town hotels i don't know so that's the end of the field marshal and hitler was sitting alone brooding and he's very miserable about this they got on all right and he's embarrassed by the whole thing well it's mortifying isn't it for him and then suddenly he thinks oh my god colonel general von fritsch has been in a scandal as well and it's hitler himself who thinks. He remembers a year or so earlier, there had been accusations against Colonel General von Fritsch.
他在战后去世了，不是吗？他在战后去世了，但在战争期间，他最终去了巴特维塞，那是“长刀之夜”发生所有行动的地方。纳粹和温泉小镇之间到底有什么联系？温泉小镇酒店，我不知道。所以这就是陆军元帅的结局，希特勒独自坐着沉思，他对此感到非常痛苦，他们相处得还不错，他对整件事感到尴尬。嗯，这对他来说很丢脸，不是吗？然后他突然想到，天哪，大将冯·弗里奇也卷入了一场丑闻。正是希特勒本人想到的。他记得一年前左右，曾有人指控大将冯·弗里奇。
And it turned out that he was being blackmailed by a Berlin rent boy called Otto Schmidt. And actually, when Fritsch hears that Hitler is all heads up about this, he sort of comes clean and says, listen, I used to have lunch with this bloke who was 18 years ago, and I did it out of charity because there was a big campaign by the Winter Aid campaign to give free meals to the needy. And because I'm a good Nazi and a pillar of the establishment, I had this bloke and I would take him for meals in public, give him lunch. And there was absolutely no scandal, no impropriety, nothing like this. I was genuinely being charitable. And actually, Tom, he was.
结果发现他被一个叫奥托·施密特的柏林男妓勒索。实际上，当弗里奇听说希特勒对此非常关注时，他坦白说，听着，我过去确实和这个家伙吃过午饭，那是 18 年前的事了，我这样做是出于慈善，因为当时有一个大型的“冬季援助运动”，为贫困者提供免费餐食。因为我是一个好纳粹，是体制的支柱，我带着这个家伙，在公共场合带他吃饭，请他吃午饭。绝对没有任何丑闻，没有任何不当行为，什么都没有。我确实是在做慈善。实际上，汤姆，他确实是。
There was no scandal whatsoever. But Hitler basically, because he's so puritanical, says, oh, well, in the context of the Blomberg business, I mean, you've got to go as well. But is he also utilizing this? Is he clearing the decks, do you think? Possibly. Possibly. I think there's got to be an element of this, that he's terribly het up about these scandals and he's very depressed about them. And he says it's the worst crisis since he became Fuhrer. But there is an opportunity here, there is a great opportunist. So both of these guys get booted out. He takes the chance to clean house, to get rid of 12 other generals, get rid of a load of guys from the Luftwaffe, and to bring in yes men. People like Wilhelm Keitel, who was at his side throughout the Second World War,
根本没有任何丑闻。但希特勒基本上，因为他太清教徒了，说，哦，好吧，在勃洛姆堡事件的背景下，我的意思是，你也得走。但他也在利用这一点吗？你认为他在清理门户吗？可能。可能。我认为这其中肯定有某种因素，他对这些丑闻感到非常烦躁，并且对此感到非常沮丧。他说这是他成为元首以来最严重的危机。但这里有一个机会，这是一个伟大的机会主义者。所以这两个人都被踢出局了。他借此机会清理门户，除掉了其他 12 名将军，除掉了一大批空军的人，并引进了唯唯诺诺的人。像威廉·凯特尔这样的人，他在整个第二次世界大战期间都站在他身边，
Walter von Brauschitz. So these are people who will basically just do his bidding. They are his creatures. And so Hitler now, I mean, he's already got all the reins of state, but now he's leader of the army as well. Exactly. And there's no one to oppose him at all. Exactly. And Tom, the reason we spent so long on it is that that is a crucial precondition for what follows. There is basically nobody to stand in his way. So let's get into the issue of Austria. So we're into 1938 and Hitler is eyeing up Austria, his southern neighbor. Now, of course, Hitler was born in Austria, brought up in austria hitler is to all intents and purposes austrian and before the first world war when he'd been growing up he had been a passionate
瓦尔特·冯·布劳希奇。所以这些人基本上只会听从他的命令。他们是他的傀儡。所以希特勒现在，我的意思是，他已经掌握了国家的所有大权，但现在他也是军队的领袖。完全正确。根本没有人反对他。完全正确。汤姆，我们花这么长时间讲这个的原因是，这是接下来发生的事情的关键前提。基本上没有人能阻挡他。那么让我们进入奥地利的问题。所以我们进入了 1938 年，希特勒正在盯着他的南部邻国奥地利。当然，希特勒出生在奥地利，在奥地利长大，希特勒实际上是奥地利人，在第一次世界大战之前，当他成长时，他一直是一个充满激情的
pan-german so he'd been one of these people who thought i hate the habsburgs i hate the czechs the slovenes all these other people i don't like the multiculturalism of Vienna that we, looking back at it from 2023, think is so brilliant. I hate all that. I wish we could turn our back on all these Slavs and Hungarians and Jews who I don't like. This is Adolf Hitler speaking, obviously.
泛德意志主义者，所以他一直是那种认为“我讨厌哈布斯堡王朝，我讨厌捷克人、斯洛文尼亚人，所有这些其他人，我不喜欢维也纳的多元文化，我们从 2023 年回望时认为那非常精彩。我讨厌这一切。我希望我们能背弃所有这些我不喜欢的斯拉夫人、匈牙利人和犹太人。”这显然是阿道夫·希特勒在说话。
And I wish German Austria, the Austrian heartland, could be united with Germany. And in those days, he would have thought under the Hohenzollerns, not under the Habsburgs. And that dream of a kind of pan-German unity has never left him at all. And obviously, there's a lot of other people in Austria who think that too. So when the Habsburg Empire fell apart in 1918, all the other bits fell away. There'd be 54 million people in the Habsburg Empire fell apart in 1918, all the other bits fell away. There'd be 54 million people in the Habsburg Empire, and now there's only 7 million of them left. And they're
我希望德意志奥地利，奥地利的心脏地带，能与德国统一。在那个时代，他会认为是在霍亨索伦王朝之下，而不是在哈布斯堡王朝之下。那种泛德意志统一的梦想从未离开过他。显然，奥地利还有很多人也这么想。所以当哈布斯堡帝国在 1918 年分崩离析时，所有其他部分都脱离了。哈布斯堡帝国有 5400 万人，现在只剩下 700 万人。他们是
German speakers. And they think, well, we don't want to live in a country called Austria. We actually want to live in Germany. And obviously the big thing at the end of the first war is about national self-determination. And it is a tiny bit unjust that the Allies said, absolutely everybody else, the Czechs, the Serbs, whatever, they can all have national self-determination, but you can't. So you cannot join Germany. For very obvious reasons. Yeah, because they don't want Germany to become bigger. Right. Absolutely. Which is precisely why Hitler wants to absorb Austria, presumably. Exactly. The Austrians actually originally wanted to call their country German Austria. absolutely which is precisely why hitler wants to absorb austria presumably exactly the austrians
德语使用者。他们想，好吧，我们不想生活在一个叫奥地利的地方。我们实际上想生活在德国。显然，一战结束时的大事是关于民族自决。盟军说，绝对每个人，捷克人、塞尔维亚人等等，他们都可以拥有民族自决，但你们不能，这确实有点不公正。所以你们不能加入德国。原因很明显。是的，因为他们不想让德国变得更大。对。绝对是。这正是希特勒想要吞并奥地利的原因，大概。完全正确。奥地利人实际上最初想把他们的国家称为德意志奥地利。
actually originally wanted to call their country german austria and the allies in the treaty of saint germain they actually banned them from choosing the name for their own country they had to call it austria rather than german austria it's just this sort of appendix i mean we now think of austria as part of the european map but at the time people just thought it was this weird leftover it's massively divided so the socialists. But at the time, people just thought of it as this weird leftover. It's massively divided. So the socialists are very popular in Vienna. People talk about Red Vienna.
实际上最初想把他们的国家称为德意志奥地利，而盟军在《圣日耳曼条约》中实际上禁止他们为自己的国家选择这个名字。他们不得不称它为奥地利而不是德意志奥地利，这就像某种附录。我的意思是，我们现在认为奥地利是欧洲地图的一部分，但在当时，人们只是认为它是一个奇怪的剩余物。它被严重分裂了，所以社会主义者。但在当时，人们只是认为它是一个奇怪的剩余物。它被严重分裂了。所以社会主义者在维也纳非常受欢迎。人们谈论“红色维也纳”。
The rest of the country, very Catholic, very, very conservative. All those nuns, singing nuns. Singing nuns, exactly. There's loads of monasteries. I've been to some monasteries in Austria, Tom. Very nice. And all the time, Hitler, who's been observing this from Germany in the 1920s, he had said German Austria should become part of Germany. And there was no doubt in his mind at all. He had said it must return to the great German mother country. One blood
国家的其他地方，非常天主教，非常、非常保守。所有那些修女，唱歌的修女。唱歌的修女，完全正确。有很多修道院。汤姆，我去过奥地利的一些修道院。非常好。一直以来，希特勒在 20 世纪 20 年代从德国观察到这一点，他说德意志奥地利应该成为德国的一部分。他心中毫无疑问。他说它必须回归伟大的德国母亲祖国。一种血缘
demands one Reich. Now, the Austrians themselves, as time goes on, they become a little bit divided about this. So particularly Catholics in Austria are a bit anxious about allying with Nazi Germany. Well, yeah, for understandable reasons. There's been a lot of tension between the Catholic Church and the Nazi regime. They don't want to be necessarily dragged into Hitler's orbit. And Austria is scarred by all kinds of economic problems, by faction fighting between the socialists and the Catholic conservatives and so on. There is a small Austrian Nazi party. But by about 1933, Austria has basically slid into a corporatist, Catholic, authoritarian
要求一个帝国。现在，随着时间的推移，奥地利人自己对这一点变得有点分歧。所以奥地利的天主教徒特别担心与纳粹德国结盟。嗯，是的，原因可以理解。天主教会和纳粹政权之间一直存在很多紧张关系。他们不想被强行拖入希特勒的轨道。奥地利被各种经济问题、社会主义者和天主教保守派之间的派系斗争等所困扰。有一个小的奥地利纳粹党。但到 1933 年左右，奥地利基本上滑向了一个法团主义、天主教、威权主义的
dictatorship under this guy called Engelbert Dollfuss, who is a very passionate kind of Catholic from rural Austria. Crazy name, crazy guy. And Dollfuss, he is absolutely tiny. I think it's literally five feet tall, Tom. He's a very short man. He puts lots of people in prison, socialists in prison. He wears a three-piece suit. He sort of walks around with his mustache and his three-piece suit talking about cardinals and stuff. So he's a bit of a Salazarist, I suppose. He's certainly not a Nazi. The Austrian Nazi Party, of course, are not happy with this at all.
独裁统治，领导人叫恩格尔伯特·多尔夫斯，他是一个来自奥地利农村的充满激情的某种天主教徒。疯狂的名字，疯狂的家伙。多尔夫斯，他绝对是个小个子。汤姆，我想他只有五英尺高。他是个非常矮的男人。他把很多人关进监狱，社会主义者关进监狱。他穿着三件套西装。他留着小胡子，穿着三件套西装走来走去，谈论红衣主教什么的。所以我想他有点像萨拉查主义者。他肯定不是纳粹。当然，奥地利纳粹党对此一点也不高兴。
There's about 70,000 of them. They don't want to live in a Catholic dictatorship. They want to live in a modern, exciting Nazi dictatorship. And in 1934, the summer, encouraged by Hitler, they tried to launch a coup. We alluded to this last time. 150 of them dressed up in army uniforms. They burst into the chancellery in Vienna. They found Dolfus trying to escape, and they shot him and tried to have a coup. And Mussolini, who was obviously quite keen on Dolfus, he said to Hitler, effectively, don't intervene.
他们大约有 7 万人。他们不想生活在天主教独裁统治下。他们想生活在一个现代、令人兴奋的纳粹独裁统治下。1934 年夏天，在希特勒的鼓励下，他们试图发动政变。我们上次提到了这一点。150 人穿着军装。他们冲进维也纳的总理府。他们发现多尔夫斯试图逃跑，他们开枪打死了他，并试图发动政变。墨索里尼，显然对多尔夫斯很感兴趣，他对希特勒说，实际上，不要干预。
Back off. He moved his army to the Brenner Pass between Austria and Italy. Yeah, back off. Hitler had to back down. So the Nazis didn't take over Austria. So weirdly, the one leader who does stand up to Hitler is Mussolini. Yeah. And demonstrates what could be done. It's true. That's weird, isn't it?
退后。他把军队调到了奥地利和意大利之间的布伦纳山口。是的，退后。希特勒不得不退缩。所以纳粹没有接管奥地利。所以奇怪的是，唯一站出来反对希特勒的领导人是墨索里尼。是的。并展示了可以做什么。这是真的。这很奇怪，不是吗？
I hadn't thought of that. That is weird. It's an irony of history. That's great. We love an irony of history and the rest is history. We certainly do. So the Nazis didn't take over Austria. The guy who took over Austria after Dolfus, three foot two, had been shot was a man called Schuschnigg. The Austrians have terrible names.
我没想到这一点。这很奇怪。这是历史的讽刺。太棒了。我们喜欢历史的讽刺，在《历史的余味》中。我们当然喜欢。所以纳粹没有接管奥地利。多尔夫斯被枪杀后接管奥地利的那个人，三英尺二英寸，是一个叫舒施尼格的人。奥地利人有可怕的名字。
Another crazy name, crazy guy. Yeah. Terrible names. When I remember doing this at GCSE and I just thought could they not have simpler names well we should apologise to all Austrian listeners for Dominic's
另一个疯狂的名字，疯狂的家伙。是的。可怕的名字。我记得在 GCSE 时做过这个，我只是想他们难道不能有更简单的名字吗？嗯，我们应该为多米尼克向所有奥地利听众道歉。
very rude comments on the names of your leaders in the 1930s yeah anyway his name is Kurt von Schnuschnig
对你们 20 世纪 30 年代领导人名字的非常粗鲁的评论。是的，无论如何，他的名字是库尔特·冯·舒施尼格。
he had been the Minister of Justice he is a sort of beaky man with glasses again another Catholic conservative but Hitler who has backed off
他曾是司法部长，他是一个戴着眼镜的尖嘴男人，同样是另一个天主教保守派，但希特勒已经退缩了，
still fancies another crack at Austria. Basically, it's his dream. Of course. Yeah, of course. That his homeland, his native land, will be reunited with the country that he currently rules. There are also really important strategic and economic reasons for the Nazis to be looking at Austria. Because the Austrians have some of the raw materials that they need for their armaments
仍然想再试一次奥地利。基本上，这是他的梦想。当然。是的，当然。他的家乡，他的祖国，将与他目前统治的国家重新统一。纳粹关注奥地利还有非常重要的战略和经济原因。因为奥地利拥有他们军备所需的一些原材料
program and for their economic agenda. So we said last time that they've adopted what they call the four-year plan under Hermann Goering. This is this massive drive to rearm and to get the economy ready for a world war. So they need iron ore, don't they? And Austria has iron ore. They need iron ore. Austria has iron ore in Styria. And Goering is desperate to get his hands on this iron ore. And in fact, by the time they've become pals with Mussolini in late 1937, Goering is always doing things like, he's always showing Mussolini maps, showing Austria as part of the German Reich and sort of saying,
计划和他们的经济议程。所以我们上次说他们已经在赫尔曼·戈林的领导下采用了所谓的“四年计划”。这是一场大规模的重新武装运动，旨在让经济为世界大战做好准备。所以他们需要铁矿石，不是吗？奥地利有铁矿石。他们需要铁矿石。奥地利在施泰尔马克有铁矿石。戈林渴望得到这些铁矿石。事实上，到 1937 年底他们与墨索里尼成为朋友时，戈林总是做一些事情，比如，他总是向墨索里尼展示地图，显示奥地利是德意志帝国的一部分，并说，
what do you think about this? Do you like the look of this map? Is this a good map? And why has Mussolini, what do you think about this? Do you like the look of this map? Do you think this is a good map? And why has Mussolini kind of shifted his opinion on this? Because previously he had been very firm about not wanting Germany to take over Austria. Because it must affect Italy's ability to defend itself. Of course. And because Austria is Italy's kind of ancestral enemy, and Italy wants to make sure that the Germans in Austria are kind of under enemy. And Italy wants to make sure that the Germans in Austria
你觉得这个怎么样？你喜欢这张地图的样子吗？这是一张好地图吗？为什么墨索里尼，你觉得这个怎么样？你喜欢这张地图的样子吗？你觉得这是一张好地图吗？为什么墨索里尼改变了对此的看法？因为以前他非常坚定地不想让德国接管奥地利。因为它必须影响意大利保护自己的能力。当然。而且因为奥地利是意大利某种世仇，意大利想确保奥地利的德国人处于某种敌对状态。意大利想确保奥地利的德国人
are kind of under their thumb, I think. I think it's because Mussolini, he's lost British and French support because of his imperialist war in Abyssinia. He has imperial ambitions in Africa and indeed in the Balkans. And if he can get Hitler's support for them, for his own new Roman empire.
处于他们的控制之下，我想。我想是因为墨索里尼，他因为在阿比西尼亚的帝国主义战争而失去了英国和法国的支持。他在非洲乃至巴尔干半岛都有帝国野心。如果他能得到希特勒对他们的支持，为了他自己的新罗马帝国。
So it's quid pro quo, basically. Yeah, the prize, he can give up Austria. Yeah. You know, they're German speakers anyway. Yeah. Give that up and he'll get Hitler's backing. Maybe he can have a crack at the Greeks or the Albanians or something. Yeah.
所以这基本上是交换条件。是的，奖品，他可以放弃奥地利。是的。你知道，他们本来就是德语使用者。是的。放弃那个，他就会得到希特勒的支持。也许他可以尝试一下希腊人或阿尔巴尼亚人什么的。是的。
So Mussolini actually doesn't say anything. And Goering thinks, well, obviously he loves it. He loves the look of this map. So early 1938 comes. Austria is still a bit of a basket case, very divided. It's never recovered from the Great Depression.
所以墨索里尼实际上什么也没说。戈林想，好吧，显然他喜欢它。他喜欢这张地图的样子。所以 1938 年初到了。奥地利仍然有点像个烂摊子，非常分裂。它从未从大萧条中恢复过来。
Hitler is kind of greedily eyeing it up. And his ambassador in Vienna is a fellow who we've talked about a few times, but has slightly disappeared in the last couple of episodes. Of course.
希特勒正贪婪地盯着它。他在维也纳的大使是我们谈论过几次的一个家伙，但在过去几集中稍微消失了。当然。
It's our old friend Franz von Papen. Yes. A Daily Telegraph columnist. Yes. The effete Machiavel yes exactly trapped actually in a greyhound's body yeah i think he looks like a greyhound anyway franz von parpen who had been hitler's vice chancellor you know had almost kind of come to a sticky end in
是我们老朋友弗朗茨·冯·帕彭。是的。《每日电讯报》专栏作家。是的。那个颓废的马基雅维利，是的，完全正确，实际上被困在灵缇犬的身体里，是的，我想他看起来像只灵缇犬。无论如何，曾任希特勒副总理的弗朗茨·冯·帕彭，你知道，在
the night of the long knives hitler had sent him off to be ambassador in vienna kind of exile right exactly parpen is a mad catholic. People with really long memories will remember that when he was in charge, a couple of chancellors before Hitler, his dream for Germany to get Germany out of its mess was to bring back the beheading people with an axe. The Prussian axe. The guillotine was too modern. Yeah, exactly. That's von Papen's contribution. Sensible policies for a happier Germany. Yeah, exactly. He's in Vienna and he says, listen, there's been a lot of tension between Austria and Germany since the beginning of 1938. I'm going to organize a meeting,
“长刀之夜”中差点以悲惨结局告终，希特勒把他派去维也纳当大使，某种流放，对吧？完全正确。帕彭是个疯狂的天主教徒。记忆力非常好的人会记得，当他掌权时，在希特勒之前的几任总理，他让德国摆脱困境的梦想是带回用斧头砍头。普鲁士斧头。断头台太现代了。是的，完全正确。那是冯·帕彭的贡献。为更幸福的德国制定明智的政策。是的，完全正确。他在维也纳，他说，听着，自 1938 年初以来，奥地利和德国之间一直有很多紧张关系。我要组织一次会议，
Schuschnigg and Hitler, and we'll do it at Hitler's kind of alpine lair, this kind of Bonn villain lair, the Berghof, the Ober Salzburg, kind of in the mountains. It's kind of Bonneville and L'air, the Berghof, the Ober Salzburg, kind of in the mountains. It's kind of eerie. So Schuschnick pitches up on the 12th of February, 1938, thinking this is going to be jolly handshakes. Yeah, kind of summit.
舒施尼格和希特勒，我们将在希特勒的某种高山巢穴，这种邦德电影里的反派巢穴，贝格霍夫，上萨尔茨堡，某种在山里。这有点像邦德电影里的反派巢穴。这有点诡异。所以舒施尼格在 1938 年 2 月 12 日赶到，认为这将是愉快的握手。是的，某种峰会。
Yeah, a nice summit between fellow German speakers. Lovely. There's a few tensions, but we're all on the same side. Robust exchange of views, but then handshakes for the cameras. Exactly. Exactly. And sort of a lot of consuming of strudels. Actually, Hitler's poor dietary issues.
是的，德语使用者之间的一次美好峰会。可爱。有一些紧张，但我们都在同一边。坦诚交换意见，然后对着镜头握手。完全正确。完全正确。还有很多吃果馅卷。实际上，希特勒糟糕的饮食问题。
Yes. Beaming girls in dirndls. Exactly. Yeah. If you're expecting that from Hitler, you're not going to get it because Hitler will just talk to you for eight hours and drink some gun cleaning fluid. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。穿着紧身连衣裙的女孩们在微笑。完全正确。是的。如果你期待希特勒那样，你不会得到的，因为希特勒只会跟你谈八个小时，喝一些枪支清洁液。是的。是的。
Anyway. Nibble on some celery. It'd be a terrible occasion in every conceivable way. The views are good. Shushnik arrives and it's actually worse than when we're selling it
无论如何。啃一些芹菜。这在任何可以想象的方式上都是一个糟糕的场合。风景很好。舒施尼格到了，实际上比我们说的还要糟糕，
because Hitler's invited some of his generals purely to intimidate Shushnik. So, Wouter von Reichenau, who's a fanatical Nazi, and a guy called Hugo Schperler, who had been the commanderical Nazi, and a guy called Hugo Speller,
因为希特勒邀请了一些将军纯粹是为了恐吓舒施尼格。所以，瓦尔特·冯·赖歇瑙，一个狂热的纳粹分子，还有一个叫雨果·施佩勒的家伙，他曾是秃鹰军团的指挥官，
who had been the commander of the Condor Legion, bombing Guernica. Oh, in Spain, yeah. In Spain. So, when Schuschnick sees these, he thinks, oh, no, what's going on here? They admire the view for about five minutes. Schuschnick says, what a beautiful view you have.
轰炸了格尔尼卡。哦，在西班牙，是的。在西班牙。所以，当舒施尼格看到这些人时，他想，哦，不，这里发生了什么？他们欣赏了大约五分钟的风景。舒施尼格说，你的风景真美。
And Hitler says, we haven't come here to talk about the weather and the view. And then he takes him inside his office and says, the whole history of Austria is an uninterrupted act of high treason this historical paradox must now reach its long overdue end i am determined to make an end of this herr schussnig i have a historic mission and i will fulfill this because providence has destined me to do so you don't believe you can hold me up for half an hour, do you? Maybe one night I'll appear overnight in Vienna like a spring storm. So not good at the small talk, it would be fair to say. When someone says that to you and you've gone for a weekend break. That's not what you want
希特勒说，我们来这里不是为了谈论天气和风景。然后他把他带进办公室说，整个奥地利的历史都是一场不间断的叛国行为，这个历史悖论现在必须结束了，我早就该结束了，赫尔·舒施尼格，我有一个历史使命，我将完成它，因为天意注定我这样做。你不相信你能阻止我半小时，对吧？也许有一天晚上我会像春天的风暴一样出现在维也纳。所以说，他不擅长闲聊，这很公平。当有人对你说这些，而你只是去度个周末假。那不是你想要的
at all, is it? It's absolutely not what you want. Now, meanwhile, Ribbentrop, who is the former champagne salesman. Who wears the wrong clothes to gentlemen's clubs in St. James. In London, exactly. Who is Hitler's foreign minister. Ribbentrop is basically handing out copies of Hitler's ultimatum. Hitler says, the Nazis who have been heavily restricted in Austria, there can be no more restrictions. Our guy, who's a guy called Arthur Seyss-Inkwart.
一点也不，是吗？那绝对不是你想要的。现在，与此同时，里宾特洛甫，那个前香槟推销员。在圣詹姆斯绅士俱乐部穿错衣服的人。在伦敦，完全正确。他是希特勒的外交部长。里宾特洛甫基本上在分发希特勒的最后通牒副本。希特勒说，在奥地利受到严格限制的纳粹分子，不能再有任何限制。我们的家伙，一个叫阿图尔·赛斯-英夸特的家伙。
Again, brilliant name. The Austrians and their names. What did I tell you? He is a guy, you should put him in charge of the Ministry of the Interior and give him control
又是绝妙的名字。奥地利人和他们的名字。我跟你说什么来着？他是一个家伙，你应该让他负责内政部并让他控制
of the police. Of course, the Nazis love control of the police. That's how they always get power. You should integrate the Austrian economic system with Germany's, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
警察。当然，纳粹喜欢控制警察。这就是他们总是获得权力的方式。你应该把奥地利的经济体系与德国的整合，等等等等。
And Schussnig is appalled by all this. Now, first, he actually says, not going to. No, absolutely not. And Hitler keeps bringing in more generals. General Keitel, for example, he says to. No, absolutely not. And Hitler keeps bringing in more generals. General Keitel, for example, he says, come in General Keitel. He just makes them sit down and they say nothing, just stare at Shushnik. Wearing intimidating uniforms,
舒施尼格对这一切感到震惊。现在，起初，他实际上说，我不干。不，绝对不。希特勒不断带进更多的将军。例如凯特尔将军，他对他说。不，绝对不。希特勒不断带进更多的将军。例如凯特尔将军，他说，进来凯特尔将军。他只是让他们坐下，他们什么也不说，只是盯着舒施尼格。穿着恐吓性的制服，
presumably. Exactly. Wearing very intimidating uniforms. And clicking their heels periodically. And eventually, at the end of the day, Shushnik, it's been a terrible day for him. And he says, fine, yes, I'd agree to most of these demands. We'll appoint this guy, Seyss Ingvarts. But what if he hadn't? Then Hitler says, I'll invade. I'll invade, my troops are ready, we'll strike. And he just browbeats and browbeats and browbeats him. And so Schussnig says, fine, I'll do it. And he goes back home. He agrees.
大概。完全正确。穿着非常恐吓性的制服。并不时点击他们的脚后跟。最终，在一天结束时，舒施尼格，对他来说这是糟糕的一天。他说，好吧，是的，我同意大部分要求。我们将任命这个家伙，赛斯-英夸特。但如果他没有呢？然后希特勒说，我会入侵。我会入侵，我的军队准备好了，我们会打击。他只是不断地恐吓、恐吓、恐吓他。所以舒施尼格说，好吧，我会做的。他回家了。他同意了。
Well, doesn't Hitler invite him for dinner? Yeah, they have to have dinner. And he says, no. He kind of says, oh, I've got a bit of a headache. I think I'll turn in early. Exactly. Exactly. Hitler kind of sometimes, he will switch. So actually in the middle of all this browbeating, Hitler had said to him, oh, we should go and have lunch. And they went and had lunch. It must've been quite an icy atmosphere. Absolutely. Yeah. They were kind of having their soup or whatever. Celery. So poor old Schuschnigg, he goes back to Vienna. He agrees to all these demands. He lets a Nazi, Seysingfa, become the Minister of the Interior.
嗯，希特勒没请他吃晚饭吗？是的，他们必须吃晚饭。他说，不。他有点说，哦，我有点头疼。我想我会早点休息。完全正确。完全正确。希特勒有时，他会转换。所以实际上在所有这些恐吓中，希特勒曾对他说，哦，我们应该去吃午饭。他们去吃了午饭。那一定是非常冰冷的气氛。绝对是。是的。他们有点在喝汤什么的。芹菜。所以可怜的舒施尼格，他回到维也纳。他同意了所有这些要求。他让一个纳粹，赛斯-英夸特，成为内政部长。
Hitler gives a speech on the radio and he says, you know, it's intolerable that Austria is still not part of the Reich, all this stuff. Loads of Nazis in Austria because it does appeal particularly to younger Austrian men who are maybe anti-clerical so you could be a socialist in austria but you would be suppressed and in fact there'd be a little civil war you could be a kind of catholic conservative in which case you'd be on schuschnigg's side or you'd be a nazi because it's the future yeah it's exciting exactly it doesn't involve monks yeah brilliant exactly exactly if you're
希特勒在广播中发表了演讲，他说，你知道，奥地利仍然不是帝国的一部分是不可容忍的，所有这些东西。奥地利有很多纳粹分子，因为它特别吸引年轻的奥地利男性，他们可能是反教权的，所以你可以在奥地利成为社会主义者，但你会受到压制，事实上会有一场小内战，你可以成为某种天主教保守派，那样你就会站在舒施尼格一边，或者你会成为纳粹，因为这是未来，是的，这很令人兴奋，完全正确，它不涉及僧侣，是的，太棒了，完全正确，如果你是
anti-monk that's what you do you've got the socialist or the Nazis so it looks like they're on this sort of path that will inevitably lead at some point to some kind of economic union you know some association something like this and then Shnig does something that nobody has anticipated. On the morning of the 9th of March, Schussnig thinks, sod it, I'm not going to drift into union with the Germans. I've come up with an idea that will get us out of this mess. A top wheeze. A wheeze. We'll have a referendum. The Nazis have been pestering and pestering for ages, saying, have a referendum on union with Germany. Schuster's like, great, we'll do it, but I'll write the question.
反僧侣，这就是你的做法，你有社会主义者或纳粹分子，所以看起来他们正走在一条不可避免地会在某个时刻导致某种经济联盟、某种协会之类的道路上，然后舒施尼格做了一件没人预料到的事情。3月9日早上，舒施尼格想，去他的，我不会就这样漂向与德国的联盟。我想出了一个能让我们摆脱困境的主意。一个绝妙的计策。一个计策。我们要举行全民公投。纳粹分子一直纠缠不休，说，举行一次关于与德国合并的公投吧。舒施尼格心想，太好了，我们就这么做，但我来写问题。
So do you want to be locked in the bloodthirsty embrace of the monstrous, overbearing tyrant? Or would you prefer to stay true to our fresh, clean, alpine republic? That's exactly it. Do you support a free true to our fresh, clean, alpine republic? That's exactly it. Do you support a free and German, independent, social Christian and united Austria? Peace and work and the equal rights for those who declare themselves a people and fatherland. And what is more, because Schuschnigg knows that the Nazis appear as to younger people, he says, you can only vote if you're over the age of 24.
那么，你想被锁在那个可怕、专横的暴君那嗜血的怀抱中吗？还是你更愿意忠于我们清新、纯洁的高山共和国？就是这样。你支持一个自由、忠于我们清新、纯洁的高山共和国吗？就是这样。你支持一个自由、德国的、独立的、社会基督教的、统一的奥地利吗？和平与工作，以及那些宣称自己属于人民和祖国的人享有平等权利。而且更重要的是，因为舒施尼格知道纳粹分子在年轻人眼中是什么样子，他说，你必须年满24岁才能投票。
So the under 24s can't vote. So kind of gerrymandering the vote. What is more. He says, you can only vote if you're over the age of 24. So the under 24s can't vote. So kind of gerrymandering the vote. What is more, he says, we'll obviously supervise this vote ourselves. And he runs a repressive regime. And I suppose the brilliant thing about this is that it is playing the Nazi game, isn't it? I mean, this is what the Nazis are doing all the time. It's absolutely doing that. And so I assume Hitler isn't pleased about it at all.
所以24岁以下的人不能投票。这算是一种操纵选区的投票。更重要的是。他说，你必须年满24岁才能投票。所以24岁以下的人不能投票。这算是一种操纵选区的投票。更重要的是，他说，我们显然会亲自监督这次投票。而他经营着一个压迫性的政权。我想这其中最精彩的地方在于，这完全是在玩纳粹的游戏，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是纳粹一直在做的事情。绝对是这样。所以我猜希特勒对此一点也不高兴。
Hitler is absolutely furious. I think what I would compare this to though tom is as a referendum idea it's a little bit like david cameron thinking i was yes yeah i haven't entirely thought this through yeah so schustnik calls this referendum and hitler for a few hours he hears the news he doesn't know what to do. But by the evening, he has gone utterly ballistic and he meets Goebbels and he says, right, no. We'll give an ultimatum. Schuschnigg must rewrite the text of the referendum.
希特勒绝对是暴跳如雷。不过汤姆，我想我会把它比作大卫·卡梅伦想出的公投主意，就像是“我当时……是的，没错，我没完全想清楚”。所以舒施尼格宣布了这次公投，希特勒在听到消息后的几个小时里，不知道该怎么办。但到了晚上，他彻底崩溃了，他见了戈培尔并说，好吧，不行。我们要发出最后通牒。舒施尼格必须重写公投的文本。
So the referendum must be inviting people now to approve a union with Germany. He will turn that down undoubtedly. When he turns that down, we will instruct the local Nazis in Austria to rise up in rebellion. And on the day of the referendum, Sunday the 13th of March, the We writes a diary. And Goebbels loves a bit of a cliche, Tom. He writes, The die is cast.
所以公投现在必须邀请人们批准与德国的合并。他无疑会拒绝。当他拒绝时，我们将指示奥地利的当地纳粹分子发动叛乱。在公投当天，即3月13日星期日，戈培尔写了日记。汤姆，戈培尔很喜欢陈词滥调。他写道，骰子已经掷下。
On Saturday, march in. Push straight to Vienna. Big aeroplane action. The Fuhrer is going himself to Austria. Goering and I are to stay in Berlin. In eight days, Austria will be ours. And will it be? Well, I think we should take a break at this point.
周六，进军。直接推进到维也纳。大规模的飞机行动。元首本人要亲自去奥地利。戈林和我留在柏林。八天之内，奥地利就是我们的了。会是这样吗？好吧，我想我们现在应该休息一下。
And when we come back, we'll find out if Austria does indeed end up in the embrace of the Führer. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History.
当我们回来时，我们将看看奥地利是否真的最终落入了元首的怀抱。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。
And Dominic, we are on the brink. Hitler has ordered his armies to prepare to invade Austria and forcibly embrace it in union with Germany. So what happens? So 10 a.m. on Friday the 11th of March 1938, Hitler sends the ultimatum to vienna and he says not only must you change your referendum so it must be now approving union with the right i mean it's so interesting showing how important it is to get the right question in a referendum yeah absolutely absolutely it is but he says also we've lost total confidence in Schussnig as an
多米尼克，我们正处于边缘。希特勒已下令他的军队准备入侵奥地利，并强行将其纳入与德国的联盟。那么发生了什么？1938年3月11日星期五上午10点，希特勒向维也纳发出了最后通牒，他说，你不仅必须改变你的公投，使其现在必须批准与帝国合并——我的意思是，这很有趣，展示了在公投中提出正确的问题是多么重要——是的，绝对是这样，但他也说，我们已经完全失去了对舒施尼格作为
honest broker. As chancellor, he must resign and be replaced by this guy, Seyss Ingvart, who is a Nazi. The interior minister. Yeah, who's the interior minister, who is our man. And if you don't do that, we will invade. Meanwhile, he sends a message to Mussolini. His go-between, bizarrely, is Prince Philip of Hesse. And Prince Philip carries this message to the Duce from Hitler that says, please stand back. Don't intervene this time. This is personal for me. This is my homeland. It will mean everything to me if you will let me do this. It's like a plaintive message. In the afternoon, Schussnig says, listen, fine, I'll postpone the referendum, but I'm not going to resign. Goering then rings this guy, Seyssenquart.
诚实中间人的信任。作为总理，他必须辞职，并由这个叫赛斯-英夸特的家伙取代，他是个纳粹分子。内政部长。是的，他是内政部长，是我们的人。如果你不这样做，我们就会入侵。与此同时，他给墨索里尼发了一条信息。奇怪的是，他的中间人是黑森的菲利普亲王。菲利普亲王把希特勒给领袖的这条信息带去，上面写着，请退后。这次不要干预。这对我来说是私事。这是我的祖国。如果你能让我这样做，对我来说意味着一切。这就像是一条哀求的信息。下午，舒施尼格说，听着，好吧，我会推迟公投，但我不会辞职。戈林随后给这个叫赛斯-英夸特的家伙打了电话。
Seyssenquart, by the way, is a weed of a man and a puppet in all this. He's the kind of Nazi bigwig in Vienna. But he's just basically doing whatever the Nazis tell him to do. And they say to him, tell him that's not good enough. Seyssenquart is always saying, oh, but is it maybe good enough? You know, do I have to? And they force him. So he goes and says, look, you absolutely got to give the Nazis whatever they want or they will invade.
顺便说一句，赛斯-英夸特是个软弱的人，在这整件事中只是个傀儡。他是维也纳纳粹高层中的一员。但他基本上只是在做纳粹告诉他做的任何事情。他们对他说，告诉他这还不够好。赛斯-英夸特总是说，哦，但这难道不够好吗？你知道，我非得这么做吗？他们强迫他。所以他去说，看，你绝对必须给纳粹他们想要的任何东西，否则他们就会入侵。
Doesn't he complain that he's being treated as no more than a girl telephone switchboard operator? He does indeed. He does indeed. Very sexist, Tom. Very sexist. Poor. But he still does it.
他难道没有抱怨自己被当作一个电话接线员对待吗？他确实抱怨了。他确实抱怨了。非常性别歧视，汤姆。非常性别歧视。可怜。但他还是照做了。
Yeah, he still does it. At that, Shusnig thinks, well, I'll go to the British. And Lord Halifax, who is the foreign secretary, he sends him a really encouraging telegram. The telegram reads, his majesty's government are unable to guarantee protection. In other words, you're on your own. So do you. You're on your own. We don't care. So Schussnig resigns. There's then a bit of a standoff while the Austrian president, whose guy called Wilhelm Mikicklash is deciding whether or not to appoint the nazi guy or not meanwhile in the streets in vienna loads of people have turned it into the streets a kind of nazi mob they're all shouting they're smashing up jewish shops they are turning exactly already they are throwing bricks through jewish shop windows
是的，他还是照做了。对此，舒施尼格想，好吧，我去找英国人。外交大臣哈利法克斯勋爵给他发了一封非常令人沮丧的电报。电报写道，国王陛下的政府无法保证提供保护。换句话说，你只能靠自己了。所以你……你只能靠自己了。我们不在乎。所以舒施尼格辞职了。随后出现了一些僵局，奥地利总统，那个叫威廉·米克拉斯的家伙，正在决定是否任命那个纳粹分子。与此同时，在维也纳街头，大量的人群涌上街头，一种纳粹暴徒，他们都在大喊大叫，他们正在砸毁犹太商店，他们正在……完全已经开始了，他们正在向犹太商店的窗户扔砖头。
okay occupying provincial government buildings the atmosphere is completely sort of hysterical and chaotic. And that evening, the Austrian president gives in. He says, I'll appoint the Nazi guy as federal chancellor. But by this point, there's nothing the Austrians can do to stop the inevitable. Because the whole thing is just crumbling away. Exactly, because the whole thing is crumbling. Hitler already has said to the army, we're not even going to wait to find out what happens in Vienna.
好吧，占领省政府大楼，气氛完全是一种歇斯底里和混乱。那天晚上，奥地利总统屈服了。他说，我会任命那个纳粹分子为联邦总理。但到了这一点，奥地利人已经无法阻止不可避免的事情了。因为整件事都在瓦解。没错，因为整件事都在瓦解。希特勒已经对军队说，我们甚至不会等待看维也纳会发生什么。
Get ready to cross the border. You're crossing tonight. Meanwhile, Mussolini is considering Hitler's request. And at 10.30 that evening, Prince Philip of Hesse tells Hitler, he says, Mussolini says, go for it. He won't intervene. And Hitler, we always think of Hitler as sort of utterly cold-blooded and calculating, but he can be very emotional because he says to Prince Philip, please tell Mussolini I will never forget him for this. Never, never, never, never, come what may. If he should ever need any help, he can be sure that do or die,
准备好越过边境。你们今晚就过境。与此同时，墨索里尼正在考虑希特勒的请求。那天晚上10点30分，黑森的菲利普亲王告诉希特勒，他说，墨索里尼说，去吧。他不会干预。而希特勒，我们总是认为希特勒是那种极其冷酷和精于算计的人，但他可以非常情绪化，因为他对菲利普亲王说，请告诉墨索里尼，我永远不会忘记他为我所做的一切。永远，永远，永远，无论发生什么。如果他将来需要任何帮助，他可以确信，无论生死，
I will stick by him, come what may, even if the whole world rises against him. You know, he's gushing. Mussolini is kind of embarrassed, isn't he, about this? He is. Mussolini is very embarrassed. He gives quite a stiff and formal reply. Thank you very much for your note.
我都会支持他，无论发生什么，即使全世界都起来反对他。你知道，他很激动。墨索里尼对此感到有点尴尬，不是吗？是的。墨索里尼非常尴尬。他给出了一个相当生硬和正式的回复。非常感谢你的来信。
Exactly. Because I think if we see Hitler as just this utterly cruel, evil automaton, you miss the kind of... Well, the hysterical quality. Yeah, the hysterical, histrionic quality of his nature. He's a man who enjoys projecting spittle. He is. He is.
没错。因为我认为如果我们只把希特勒看作是一个极其残忍、邪恶的自动机，你就会错过那种……嗯，歇斯底里的特质。是的，他天性中歇斯底里、戏剧化的特质。他是一个喜欢喷着唾沫说话的人。他是。他是。
And there's a kind of... He can be sentimental about things. I mean, about dogs. Well, he's sentimental about animals. Yes, animals and little children. Exactly. And Austria. Well, and the destruction of Austria he's sentimental about rather than Austria per
而且有一种……他可以在某些事情上表现得感性。我是说，关于狗。嗯，他对动物很感性。是的，动物和小孩子。没错。还有奥地利。嗯，他是对奥地利的毁灭感到感性，而不是对奥地利本身，
se, because that is what his dream is, to destroy Austria because he sees it as a historical act of treachery so at 5 30 on the morning of saturday the 12th of march the german army crosses the border and the austrians have issued instructions there is to be no resistance at all and they are met by massive crowds people are throwing flowers at them people are excited now historians have debated is this just because there are a lot of nazis there is it because people are frightened or people just apolitical swept up in enthusiasm yeah is it exciting it's you know it's a change i mean it's incredibly exciting as a spectacle right yeah and they think wrongly we are going to join as equal partners in this fantastic new empire. I think they don't realize the extent to which Hitler sees them as
因为这就是他的梦想，摧毁奥地利，因为他将其视为一种历史性的背叛行为。所以，在3月12日星期六早上5点30分，德国军队越过了边境，奥地利人已经发布了指示，绝对不能有任何抵抗，他们受到了大量人群的欢迎，人们向他们投掷鲜花，人们很兴奋。现在历史学家们一直在争论，这仅仅是因为那里有很多纳粹分子，还是因为人们感到害怕，或者人们只是非政治化地被热情所席卷？是的，这很令人兴奋，你知道，这是一种改变，我的意思是，作为一个奇观，这令人难以置信地兴奋，对吧？是的，他们错误地认为，我们将作为平等的伙伴加入这个奇妙的新帝国。我认为他们没有意识到希特勒在多大程度上将他们视为
utterly subordinate. So a kind of England-Scotland kind of union. Exactly. But in fact, it's a complete absorption. Because at that point, Hitler is not actually thinking about an Anschluss. Even at that point, a complete absorption of Austria. He's actually thinking there'll be some kind of union between the two countries. So not necessarily absorbing Austria into the Reich straight away. Anyway, the troops continue into Austria. And that afternoon, just before four o'clock, Hitler himself crosses the Austrian border and he crosses at his own birthplace, which was on the border. His father, Alois, was a customs official. So it's a place called Braunau Amin.
完全的下属。所以是一种英格兰-苏格兰式的联盟。没错。但事实上，这是一种完全的吞并。因为在那个时候，希特勒实际上并没有考虑德奥合并。即使在那个时候，也不是对奥地利的完全吞并。他实际上认为两国之间会有某种联盟。所以不一定马上把奥地利吸收到帝国中。总之，部队继续进入奥地利。那天下午，就在四点之前，希特勒本人越过了奥地利边境，他在自己的出生地越境，那个地方就在边境上。他的父亲阿洛伊斯是一名海关官员。所以这是一个叫布劳瑙的地方。
And they're ringing the church bells. There are tens of thousands of people. So the little town's population has been swelled by fans who've come to see him. His car goes really, really slowly. So he doesn't spend much time in Braunau Amin because he's only really born there. He spends most of his time when he's only really born there. He spends most of his time when he's a child in Linz, the suburb of Linz. And is there a lot of kind of
教堂的钟声在响。有成千上万的人。所以这个小镇的人口被来看他的粉丝们膨胀了。他的车开得非常非常慢。所以他在布劳瑙待的时间并不长，因为他只是在那里出生。他大部分时间……他只是在那里出生。他大部分时间是在林茨度过的，林茨的郊区。那里有很多那种
Beatlemania-type behavior? Total Beatlemania behavior. Sobbing, weeping, cheering. So we talked about this in the episode that you did about Nuremberg rallies. Yeah. It's very Beatlemania. It takes him about four hours to drive
披头士狂热式的行为吗？完全是披头士狂热的行为。啜泣、哭泣、欢呼。所以我们在你做的关于纽伦堡集会的剧集中谈到了这一点。是的。这非常像披头士狂热。他花了大约四个小时才开车
the relatively short distance to Linz. He gets there in the evening. The crowd is so thick in Linz, they can't really get through. The bells are ringing. You can't hear a word anybody is saying because people are screaming so loud. When Hitler goes out on the balcony of Linz Town Hall, he is crying. There are tears running down his cheeks. And he says this whole thing that he's saying a lot these days, Providence has chosen me to bring Austria into the Reich. I have fulfilled my mission. And his sense of emotion, his sense that Austria is welcoming what he is doing for it as he sees it, this changes his mind, doesn't it? Totally. It makes him think, actually, this is what the Austrians want. I'm going to absorb Austria completely into the body politic of
走完到林茨相对较短的距离。他晚上到达那里。林茨的人群太拥挤了，他们根本无法通过。钟声在响。你听不到任何人说的任何话，因为人们尖叫得太响了。当希特勒走到林茨市政厅的阳台上时，他在哭。泪水顺着他的脸颊流下来。他说着他这些天经常说的那整套话，天意选择了我将奥地利带入帝国。我已经完成了我的使命。他那种情绪感，他那种认为奥地利正在欢迎他所做的事情的感觉，这改变了他的想法，不是吗？完全改变了。这让他觉得，实际上，这就是奥地利人想要的。我要把奥地利完全吸收到
Germany. Exactly. Exactly. When we were researching this, I was thinking a lot about Hitler's psychology. He had been an idealistic boy, a dreamer who goes to all these Wagner operas, and the classic case of somebody who life doesn't match up to his dreams because he's so useless and he has this burning sense of resentment and this is the moment that probably deep down so many people dream of it's like going back to your old school yeah and all your former enemies bowing down before you yeah yeah it's a very common human fantasy that most people ultimately grow out of a little bit they maybe nurse it in a sort of silly way but for hitler i think this is a transcendent moment why he's crying there on the balcony he had been scorned
德国的政治主体中。没错。没错。当我们研究这个的时候，我一直在思考希特勒的心理。他曾经是一个理想主义的男孩，一个去听所有瓦格纳歌剧的梦想家，这是那种生活与梦想不符的典型案例，因为他太没用了，他有一种强烈的怨恨感，而这可能是内心深处许多人梦想的时刻，就像回到你的老学校，你以前所有的敌人都向你鞠躬，是的，这是一种非常普遍的人类幻想，大多数人最终会从中成长一点，他们可能会以一种愚蠢的方式怀念它，但对于希特勒，我认为这是一个超越的时刻，为什么他在阳台上哭泣，他曾被蔑视，
he hadn't got into the flipping art school in vienna, failed the exam. He'd been on the streets. He'd been nothing. And now he is, in his own mind, the greatest man in Austrian history. And people are crying in front of him with joy at his very presence. And so what does this mean in practical terms for the future of Austria? Well, the pure practicalities, Tom, there's more hotel-based action. Tremendous. Which I know you always enjoy.
他没能进入维也纳那该死的艺术学校，考试不及格。他曾在街头流浪。他什么都不是。而现在，在他自己的心目中，他是奥地利历史上最伟大的人。人们在他面前因他的出现而喜极而泣。那么这对奥地利的未来在实际层面上意味着什么呢？嗯，纯粹的实际情况，汤姆，有更多的酒店活动。太棒了。我知道你总是很喜欢。
They go to the Hotel Weizsinger. There aren't enough bedrooms. It's all a bit of a shambles. The restaurant can't cope, can't produce enough food for them. It's all very unexpected. All those elderly waiters.
他们去了魏辛格酒店。卧室不够。一切都有点混乱。餐厅应付不过来，无法为他们生产足够的食物。这一切都非常出乎意料。那些上了年纪的服务员。
Yeah, very faulty towers. Yeah. Bringing out dumplings and goulash and schnitzels and stuff. Yeah, the schnitzels off. There's only one telephone in the hotel.
是的，非常像《弗尔蒂旅馆》。是的。端出饺子、炖牛肉和炸肉排之类的东西。是的，炸肉排没了。酒店里只有一部电话。
So communications with Berlin are very difficult. But basically, Hitler says, you know what? We won't bother with all the long business of union. So he sends instructions, send lawyers to the hotel. We'll draft the law in the hotel. And as mad as it sounds, the next day, which is a Sunday, civil servants and lawyers pitch up and they literally sit downstairs in the kind of restaurant in the lobby of the hotel drafting the laws that will incorporate austria into the right so austria
所以与柏林的通讯非常困难。但基本上，希特勒说，你知道吗？我们不用费心去搞那些漫长的联盟事务了。所以他发出指示，派律师到酒店来。我们在酒店起草法律。听起来很疯狂，第二天，也就是星期天，公务员和律师们赶来，他们真的坐在酒店大堂的餐厅里，起草将奥地利纳入帝国的法律，所以奥地利
would just become a german province basically just become a german province just like anything else like bavaria had done exactly so it's nationhood its sense of distinctiveness which of course has deep historical roots because it's always been the hapsburg heartland and it's of course very catholic when so much of germany's protestant that will all just be swept away so meanwhile while they're drafting the laws and the sort of waiters are running around them increasingly agitated hitler goes off to his parents grave puts flowers on his parents grave he goes to look at his old childhood house. He meets some old neighbors. It's all, you know, so what have you been up to? Yeah. But it's very, for him, it's
基本上就会变成一个德国省份，就像巴伐利亚所做的那样，没错，所以它的民族性，它的独特性感，当然有着深厚的历史根源，因为它是哈布斯堡王朝的核心地带，而且它当然非常天主教，而德国大部分是新教，这一切都将被扫除。所以与此同时，当他们起草法律，服务员在他们周围越来越焦躁地跑来跑去时，希特勒去看了他父母的坟墓，在他父母的坟墓上放了花，他去看了他童年的老房子。他遇到了一些老邻居。这一切，你知道，所以你最近在忙什么？是的。但对他来说，这非常
very, very moving. Of course. He sends Mussolini another message. Mussolini, I will never forget you for this. Mussolini again, slightly stiff and embarrassed reply. My stance was determined by the friendship between our two countries sealed in the Axis. And that evening, the Austrians just accept the law. The army is sworn into Hitler. They basically give him, totally give him. Sure, we'll be just another part of Germany like any other part. Next day, Monday, he goes to Vienna.
非常感人。当然。他给墨索里尼发了另一条信息。墨索里尼，我永远不会忘记你为我所做的一切。墨索里尼再次给出了稍微生硬和尴尬的回复。我的立场是由我们两国之间在轴心国中密封的友谊所决定的。那天晚上，奥地利人只是接受了这项法律。军队向希特勒宣誓效忠。他们基本上完全给了他。当然，我们会成为德国的另一部分，就像任何其他部分一样。第二天，星期一，他去了维也纳。
Okay, so Vienna, Red Vienna. Yeah. Lots of socialists. Yeah. Lots of Jews. Yes. What's the reaction. Yeah. Lots of Jews. Yes. What's the reaction there? Total ecstasy.
好吧，那么维也纳，红色维也纳。是的。有很多社会主义者。是的。有很多犹太人。是的。反应是什么？是的。有很多犹太人。是的。那里的反应是什么？完全的狂喜。
We'll just come into the socialists and the Jews in a second, Tom, because it's really important that you mention that. But on the face of it, total Beatlemania ecstasy. A quarter of a million people in the streets. Now, this has slightly been rigged. A lot of workplaces and factories have closed, and employees have been told they will be paid anyway, but they have to go to join the crowd.
汤姆，我们稍后再谈社会主义者和犹太人，因为你提到这一点真的很重要。但从表面上看，完全是披头士狂热式的狂喜。街上有二十五万人。现在，这稍微有点被操纵了。许多工作场所和工厂已经关闭，员工被告知无论如何都会得到报酬，但他们必须去加入人群。
But all of that said, even Ian Kershaw, who really goes into all this, says the enthusiasm is not contrived. The enthusiasm is genuine. Hitler is on the balcony once again of the Hotel Imperial, and then he gives a speech in the Heldenplatz. There are vast, vast crowds of youngsters who are screaming and cheering and sobbing. Every Catholic church in the city is flying the swastika
但话虽如此，即使是真正深入研究这一切的伊恩·克肖也说，这种热情并非人为制造。这种热情是真诚的。希特勒再次站在帝国酒店的阳台上，然后在英雄广场发表了演讲。有大量大量的年轻人尖叫、欢呼和啜泣。城里的每一座天主教教堂都在悬挂纳粹旗，
on the orders of their local cardinal, Cardinal Initzer, who's the Archbishop of Vienna. They can't sleep, the Nazis, in the hotel. It's very Beatlemania. They can't sleep because people are outside cheering them and screaming and saying, we want to see the Fuhrer. Sending the chambermaids in to steal the sheets and snap them up and sell them as souvenirs and all that kind of thing.
这是在他们的当地红衣主教，维也纳大主教因尼策尔的命令下进行的。纳粹分子在酒店里睡不着觉。这非常像披头士狂热。他们睡不着，因为外面的人在为他们欢呼、尖叫，说，我们要见元首。派女佣进去偷床单，把它们抢走，当作纪念品卖掉，诸如此类的事情。
Exactly. It's an extraordinary, extraordinary scene. And for Hitler, it's... Apotheosis, I suppose. Absolute apotheosis. Totally invigorating. So it won't be doing anything to stop his messiah complex? Not at all.
没错。这是一个非凡的、非凡的场景。对于希特勒来说，这是……我想是神化。绝对的神化。完全令人振奋。所以这不会阻止他的弥赛亚情结？一点也不会。
He eventually goes back to Berlin. They have a big plebiscite, both in Germany and in Austria. Both results, 99% plus. Oh, yes. You know, there's obviously the usual intimidation and whatnot. Yeah. But, as Kershaw says, for the mass of the German people, Hitler once more seemed a statesman of extraordinary virtuoso talents.
他最终回到了柏林。他们在德国和奥地利都进行了大规模的公民投票。两个结果都是99%以上。哦，是的。你知道，显然有通常的恐吓之类的东西。是的。但是，正如克肖所说，对于广大的德国人民来说，希特勒再次看起来是一位具有非凡精湛才华的政治家。
Yeah, he has pulled off an extraordinary coup. And for the Austrians, they've kind of voted with great enthusiasm for this. Yeah. Beatlemania scenes, all this kind of thing. But as we said earlier, the Nazi high command are basically set on plundering Austria, aren't they?
是的，他完成了一场非凡的政变。对于奥地利人来说，他们以极大的热情投票支持了这一点。是的，披头士狂热的场景，所有这些事情。但正如我们之前所说，纳粹最高指挥部基本上是铁了心要掠夺奥地利，不是吗？
Yeah. Yeah. So how long does it take the Austrians to realize what they've actually signed up to? said earlier the nazi high command are basically set on plundering austria aren't they yeah yeah so how long does it take the austrians to realize what they've actually signed up to weeks months maybe they're not equal partners at all they're merely the eastern march ostmark is what they're called and eventually in 1942 the ostmark itself is divided into two reich regions the alps and the danube so austria vanishes completely from the map. Austria completely vanishes from the map. The local Austrian Nazis, for whom this had been a moment long dreamed of, they end up being supplanted by people sent from Berlin. So a measure of poetic justice there then.
是的。是的。那么奥地利人需要多长时间才能意识到他们实际上签署了什么？正如之前所说，纳粹最高指挥部基本上是铁了心要掠夺奥地利，不是吗？是的。是的。那么奥地利人需要多长时间才能意识到他们实际上签署了什么？几周，几个月，也许他们根本不是平等的伙伴，他们仅仅是东方边疆区，这就是他们被称为“Ostmark”的原因，最终在1942年，东方边疆区本身被划分为两个帝国大区，阿尔卑斯和多瑙河，所以奥地利完全从地图上消失了。奥地利完全从地图上消失了。当地的奥地利纳粹分子，对于他们来说，这是一个期待已久的时刻，他们最终被从柏林派来的人所取代。所以那里有一种诗意的正义。
Yes, exactly. All the Austrian institutions, the railways, the banks, the postal service, everything else, the army, all these things. They lose their meaning, of course, and postal service, everything else, the army, all these things. They lose their meaning. Of course. And they end up being bossed around and treated like kind of country bumpkins. And the iron ore. And of course the iron ore, which Goering wanted.
是的，没错。所有的奥地利机构，铁路、银行、邮政服务，其他一切，军队，所有这些东西。它们失去了意义，当然，邮政服务，其他一切，军队，所有这些东西。它们失去了意义。当然。他们最终被呼来喝去，被当作乡巴佬对待。还有铁矿石。当然还有戈林想要的铁矿石。
That's taken to Germany. He gets his fat hands on it. He gets his fat hands on the gold in Vienna, the Viennese bank's gold, their foreign currency reserves, even art is taken. So the classic example of this, we alluded to this in the Nuremberg Rallys episodes, banks, gold, their foreign currency reserves, even art is taken. So the classic example of this, we alluded to this in the Nuremberg Morales episodes, the crown jewels of the Holy Roman Empire are taken from Vienna to Nuremberg. So they'd been moved from Nuremberg, hadn't they, to Vienna?
那被带到了德国。他把肥手伸向了它。他把肥手伸向了维也纳的黄金，维也纳银行的黄金，他们的外汇储备，甚至艺术品也被拿走了。所以这方面的典型例子，我们在纽伦堡集会的剧集中提到了这一点，银行、黄金、他们的外汇储备，甚至艺术品也被拿走了。所以这方面的典型例子，我们在纽伦堡集会的剧集中提到了这一点，神圣罗马帝国的皇冠珠宝被从维也纳带到了纽伦堡。所以它们之前是从纽伦堡搬到维也纳的，不是吗？
Yes. And now they get them back. So they won't be bothering with replicas anymore. All this kind of, you know, the Nazis moving in, removing industrial capacity, removing the gold reserves from the bank, plundering the art. This is the prototype for what will happen in the Nazi occupation of Europe during the Second World War, isn't it? So to that extent, the way that Austria after the war presents itself as the first victim
是的。现在他们拿回去了。所以他们不会再费心去搞复制品了。所有这些，你知道，纳粹搬进来，移除工业能力，从银行移除黄金储备，掠夺艺术品。这是纳粹在第二次世界大战期间占领欧洲时所发生事情的原型，不是吗？所以从这个程度上说，奥地利战后将自己呈现为纳粹征服战争的第一个受害者，我的意思是，这并非不准确。在某种程度上，这并非不准确。所以显然欢呼的人群并不容易被接受。是的，那很尴尬。是的。然后是巨大的热情。但这就像被一个非常有诱惑力的男朋友迷住了一样。是的。然后发现他在偷你的钱并殴打你。是的。在某种程度上确实如此，而殴打，汤姆，所以让我们
of the Nazi wars of conquest, I mean, it's not inaccurate. To that degree, it's not inaccurate. So obviously the cheering crowds don't sit easily. Yes, that's an embarrassment. Yeah. And then massive enthusiasm. But it's like being kind of swept off your feet by a very seductive boyfriend. Yes. And then finding that he's nicking all your money and beating you up. Yeah. To some extent it is and the beating up tom so let's
进入这个话题，一夜之间，当纳粹进入时，他们控制了奥地利警察记录，并在一个晚上拘留了21,000人，这种压迫规模让欧洲感到震惊和恐惧。有些人被杀。很多人，那种纳粹批评者，逃跑了。舒施尼格没有逃跑，实际上最终进了监狱，不是吗，汤姆？我想他最终进了集中营。是的，他最终进了集中营。他在战争结束时差点死了。但和其他一些非常杰出的囚犯一起，他逃脱了。他最终成为了圣路易斯的一名教授。他成为了美国公民。是的，他确实。
get into this overnight when the nazis moved in they took control of the austrian police records and they detained in one evening 21 000 people this is a scale of repression that astounds and horrifies Europe. Some people are killed. Lots of people, sort of Nazi critics, flee. Schuschnigg didn't flee and actually ended up in prison, didn't he, Tom? He ends up in a concentration camp, I think. Yeah, he ends up in a concentration camp. And he almost dies at the end of the war. But along with other kind of very distinguished prisoners, he escapes. He ends up as a professor in St. Louis. He becomes a US citizen. Yeah, he does.
非凡。他确实。我也注意到了。我想，这真是奇怪，非常克伦斯基式的行为。我想知道他们在1950年代的美国是否为所有之前管理过被独裁者接管的国家的人举行过学术会议。总之，还有其他人被杀。那犹太人呢？最严重的压迫显然落在了奥地利的犹太人身上。而且
Extraordinary. He does. I noticed that too. I thought, what a strange, very Kerensky kind of behavior. I wonder if they had academic conferences in America in the 1950s for all the people who previously run countries that have been taken over by dictators. Anyway, various other people are killed. And what about the Jews? The worst of the repression obviously falls on Austria's Jews. And
这确实是我们开始进入那种真正的黑暗的地方。所以奥地利大约有20万犹太人，绝大多数住在维也纳。现在，我们在第一个纳粹系列的最开始谈到了希特勒在第一次世界大战前在维也纳作为一个年轻人所遇到的强烈反犹主义，它有一种远超当时德国任何地方的毒性和恶毒。而维也纳对德奥合并的反应绝对是令人恐惧的。所以维也纳几乎所有犹太人拥有的企业都被直接接管了。犹太商业领袖被杀。像德意志银行或法本公司这样的公司，漫不经心地，
this is really where we start to get into the kind of the real darkness. So there are about 200,000 Jews in Austria and the vast, vast majority of them lived in Viennaienna now we talked right at the very beginning of our first nazi series about the intense anti-semitism that hitler had encountered as a young man in vienna in vienna before the first world war that it had a virulence and a venom that was well beyond anything in germany at the same time and the reaction to the Anschluss in Vienna is absolutely horrifying. So almost all Jewish-owned businesses in Vienna are taken over straight away. Jewish business leaders are killed. Companies like Deutsche Bank or IG Farben blithely,
你知道，一旦他们死了，他们就接管了他们的企业。他们难道没有把犹太银行行长塞进车里，然后在车速达到每小时80英里时把他们扔出去吗？是的，绝对没错，正是这样，那个经营信贷银行的人，那可能是中欧最大的银行，他被扔出了车，完全正确，而且臭名昭著的场景是犹太人被迫在人们观看时擦洗街上的反纳粹口号，人们在他们身上泼冷水，向他们泼酸，可怕的场景。维也纳是一个非常政治化的城市。所以它到处都是政治涂鸦。很多，你知道，舒施尼格的党徒，他控制了奥地利最大的政党。所以有很多支持舒施尼格的涂鸦。犹太人团体，男人和女人，年轻人和老人，
you know, once they're dead, they take over their enterprises. And don't they get the Jewish heads of banks into cars and kind of chuck them out when they're going at 80 miles an hour yes absolutely right exactly the guy who runs the credit and stouts which is probably the biggest bank in central europe he was thrown as a car exactly right and the notorious scenes are that jews are made to scrub anti-nazi slogans from the streets while people watch and kind of throw cold water over them and flake acid at them and horrible scenes. Vienna was a very political city. So it was covered with political graffiti. A lot of it, you know, Schussnig's partisans, he had controlled the biggest party in Austria. So there's loads of pro-Schussushnik graffiti. Groups of Jews, men and women, young and old,
孩子，老人，无论什么，他们被所谓的清理小队拖出来，被迫擦洗这些口号。还有人群，你可以看到照片，你可以读到报纸报道，它们很可怕。人群会站在他们周围，嘲笑他们，踢他们，打他们，向他们吐口水，向他们泼冷水，正如你所说。有一个叫乔治·格贾的人，他是《每日电讯报》的记者。他写了这些非常非常令人痛苦的关于维也纳的报道，关于站在这些人周围的纳粹暴徒，正如你所说，向他们泼酸并嘲笑他们。而这些纳粹分子是奥地利人。奥地利纳粹分子。奥地利纳粹分子。坦率地说，汤姆，
kids, the elderly, whatever, they're dragged out by so-called cleaning squads and they are forced to scrub these slogans. And groups of people, you can see photos, you can read the newspaper reports, they're horrific. Groups of people would stand around them, jeering at them, kicking them, punching them, spitting at them, throwing cold, punching them, spitting at them, throwing cold water over them, as you say. There was a guy called George Gedja, who was the correspondent for the Daily Telegraph. And he wrote these really, really harrowing kind of dispatches from Vienna about the mobs of Nazis standing around these people, as you said, throwing acid at them and laughing at them. And these Nazis are Austrian. Austrian Nazis. Austrian Nazis. And frankly, Tom,
普通的奥地利人。嗯，因为有一个故事，不是吗，一个人从窗户往外看，看到一个警察在殴打一个犹太人。是的。他意识到这是一个他认识了一辈子的警察。没错，是的。他们难道没有那种人性吗？一个叫，他最终被称为乔治·克莱尔，因为他搬到了英国。
ordinary Austrians. Well, because there's a story, isn't there, of a guy looking out of a window and seeing a policeman beating up a Jew. Yeah. And he realizes that this is a policeman he's known all his life. Exactly, yeah. Didn't they have it in him? A guy called, he ends up being called George Clare because he moved to England.
他叫格奥尔格·克莱尔。他写了一本书叫《维也纳最后的华尔兹》，如果听众想读更多关于这方面的内容，我会推荐给他们。你可以完全理解为什么你不会读。他描述了，正如你所说，从窗户往外看，看到那些因仇恨而扭曲的脸，以及他认识的人，他们的邻居之类的。许多犹太人试图逃往捷克边境。
He was called Georg Clare. And he wrote a book called Last Waltz in Vienna, which I will recommend to the listeners if they want to read more about this. You can completely understand why you wouldn't. And he describes, as you say, looking out of his window, seeing the faces contorted with hatred and the people he knows, their neighbors and things. A lot of Jews try to flee to the Czech border.
这太可怕了。成千上万的人，他们上了最后一班火车之类的，但人们在车站伏击他们，抢走他们的财产，殴打他们，当他们到达捷克边境时，捷克人把他们赶了回来，所以他们试图穿过树林之类的，他们处于一种无人区，很多人自杀了，数百人，是的，自杀率大幅上升，因为此时对很多人来说，很多犹太人，嗯，我的意思是，最著名的是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德已经离开了，是的，你知道，我们陷入了
It's terrible. Thousands, they get onto the last trains and stuff, but people ambush them at the stations and are taking their property beating them up when they get to the czech border the czechs are turning them back so they're trying to get through the woods and stuff they're in kind of no man's land loads of people kill themselves hundreds of people yeah suicide rate massively goes up because it's obvious to a lot of people at this point a lot of jewish people well i mean most famously sigmund freud has already left yes that you know we are plunged
这种难以置信的噩梦中，是的，所以汤姆，为了总结一下，因为我知道我们已经谈了很长时间了，未来有一个可怕的预兆，那就是面对这一切，纳粹分子想，你知道，让我们把这些犹太人都赶走，因为他们现在多了20万犹太人，这大约是已经从德国移民出去的人数，是的，大致正确，所以他们基本上现在回到了原点，就他们所见，是的，他们建立了一个犹太移民中央机构，将与一些精心挑选的犹太领导人合作，他们找来负责那个机构的人是一个来自党卫军的人，他是一个叫阿道夫·艾希曼的人，他在第一次世界大战前住在奥地利，艾希曼是狂热的，但他也是
into this unbelievable nightmare yeah so tom just to wrap up because i know we've been talking at great length there's one terrible omen of the future which is that in the face of all this the nazis think you know let's kick all these jews out because they've now got an extra 200 000 jews which is about the number that's already emigrated from germany yes roughly right so they're basically now back to square one as far as they see it yeah and they set up a central agency for jewish emigration that's going to work in collaboration with some hand-picked jewish leaders and the guy they get to run that is a man from the ss and he is a man called adolf eichmann who had lived in austria before the first world war eichmann is fanatical but he's also
令人难以置信的有条理，他工作，你知道，他是个官僚，好吧，在他编制名单和所有这些事情中，你可以看到一个在第二次世界大战期间会以更险恶的形式重现的模式，是的，在我们结束之前还有一点，这显然对希特勒本人产生了巨大的影响，他回到德国时比以往任何时候都更受欢迎，受到了巨大、压倒性的喜悦爆发的欢迎，他现在已经实现了德国民族主义者几乎所有的野心，正如伊恩·克肖所说，包括德奥合并在内。希特勒证明了一位完美的民族主义政治家。所以他迄今为止所做的一切都是任何军国主义、威权主义、保守主义、某种收复失地的德国领导人会做的事情
incredibly methodical and he works you know he's a bureaucrat okay and in his compiling of lists and all of this you can see a pattern that will recur in an even more sinister form during the second world war yeah one other quick point before we pack up this obviously has a colossal impact on hitler himself he returns more popular than ever in germany greeted with an enormous overwhelming explosion of joy He has fulfilled almost all of the ambitions now of German nationalists, as Ian Kershaw says, down to and including the Anschluss. Hitler had proved a consummate nationalist politician. So all of the stuff he's done so far is what any militaristic, authoritarian, conservative, sort of irredentist german leader would have done
而且他做到了，没有引发战争，没有引发战争，这是一个惊人的成就，然而，是的，关于希特勒的整件事是，这还不够，他还有更多的事情排着队，即使这一切正在结束，几天之内，他就对戈培尔说，好吧，下一个是捷克斯洛伐克，好吧，你谈到了犹太人是如何被强迫移民或试图逃过边境并自杀或被枪杀或诸如此类的事情，回到另一群著名的德国流亡者，冯·特拉普一家，我们开始时提到的。是的。任何看过这部电影的人都会记得他们徒步翻越阿尔卑斯山进入瑞士。那实际上并不是发生的事情。
and he's done it without provoking war without provoking war an astounding achievement and yet yeah the whole thing about hitler is that it is not enough he has got more stuff lined up and even as this is ending within days he says to goebbels right czechoslovakia next right okay you talked about how jews are strong-armed into emigration or are trying to escape across the border and committing suicide there or being shot or whatever just to go back to another famous group of exiles from Germany, the von Trapps, who we began with. Yeah. Anyone who has seen the film will remember that they go by foot over the Alps into Switzerland. That is not actually what happened.
不。因为格奥尔格·冯·特拉普，你知道，他是一名军官。他不是犹太人。他的旅行没有任何限制。所以即使德国最高指挥部非常希望他去不来梅港加入那里的德国海军，他也没有去。他带着他的家人。他们上了火车去了意大利。从那里他们去了伦敦，然后从那里去了美国。所以对一些人来说，离开奥地利很容易，而对其他人来说则不那么容易，是的，因为正如你所说，如果他是犹太人，那将是一个非常不同的故事，我的意思是，一个完全不同的故事。
No. Because Georg von Trapp, you know, he was an army officer. He wasn't Jewish. There were no restrictions on his travel whatsoever. So even though the German high command were very keen that he go to Bremenhaven and join the Kriegmarine there, he doesn't. He takes his family. They get on a train and they go to Italy. And from there they go to London and from there to the United States. So it's easy for some people to get out of austria and less easy for others yeah because as you say had he been jewish it would have been a very different story i mean a totally different story
是的，所以在下一集中，我们将尝试通过纳粹的眼睛看世界，我们将尝试理解纳粹自己是如何看待他们所做的事情是正确的事情，你知道，他们并没有坐在一起说，我们是坏人吗？然后我们将看看德国的犹太人发生了什么，针对他们的法律升级，看看移民和迫害的过程，多米尼克，你对维也纳发生的事情的描述，是一种我们将在德国背景下讨论的事情的恐怖预兆。所以，汤姆，这一周的剧集有一个稍微阴郁的结尾，但这是一个阴郁的主题。是的，但非常重要的主题。没错。重要且迷人。再见。
yeah so in the next episode we're going to try and see the world through nazi eyes we're going to try and understand how the nazis themselves viewed what they were doing as being the right thing to do you know they weren't sitting around saying are we the baddies? And then we are going to look at what is happening to Jews in Germany, the escalation of laws that are brought in against them, and look at the process of emigration and of persecution, which Dominic, your account of what happened in Vienna is a kind of horrific prefiguring of what we'll be talking about in the context of Germany. So a slightly grim ending, Tom, to this week's episode, but a grim subject. Yeah, but very important subject. Exactly. Important and fascinating. Bye-bye.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得……目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想收听无广告版本、获取额外剧集并抢先收听，目前本集尚无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。